siamo ritornati amici e oggi è un video
un po strano perché facciamo commentiamo
delle cose successe
come sapete è youtube è stracolmo di
contenuti quindi un sacco di gente ogni
tanto fa dei video dove mi mette nel
titolo ok è da un po che non non
commento determinate cose quindi andiamo
a vedere che cosa è successo io mi è
saltato all'occhio in settimana che è
uscito sto video di sottomarina york
fire su siffatte la scarsa bar challenge
dove c'è pietro che è uguale uguale la
korea non ho visto niente la tua bello
regista faccio una mini reaction a
questo ed altre robe che adesso andremo
a vedere
vediamolo bella ragazza sono falli jey
vorrei che la partenza è fantastica per
due motivi 1 i miei capelli due jeep chi
sei kiss kiss ei sì iscritto iscritto
mandateli dei milioni a quest'uomo non
ci sono ipantellas ciao ragazzi della
ragazza c'è anche pietro
[Musica]
che bello pietro e sotto benissimo c'è
un dente solo va bene continuiamo già si
prospetta un capolavoro
vabbè oggi ci sfideremo nella crossbar
challenge avremo 64 piselli vabbè dietro
questa la dobbiamo vincere guardali non
destano preoccupazioni non possiamo
perdere ovviamente la salvione mondiale
nel prendere la traversa quindi per me è
un gioco da ragazzi mi chiama è caduto
tra l'altro l'anno tra l'altro l'anno
l'hanno fatto benissimo cioè nel senso
pietro quando calcia quando calcia il
pallone è ancora peggio di così però ok
è la mia faccia dice tutto meraviglia s
10 su 10 stupide a si è andata fuori ea
giro
vabbè grosso trova il pari grosso
[Musica]
una volta mi succede service che fate ma
mi aspetto la tentazione
[Musica]
però a me questo prende la traversa
anche scoraggiando sul pallone no però
detto che chi lo buca vo dannati giovani
non riuscirò più quali una volta sono
gli atc allevavano geniale basta bisogna
bellissimi complimenti veramente non so
cosa dirti bravo bravo bravo che questi
sono i video manna si sta roba qua
consigliati per te fa vj davvero mi
consigli fa vj non conosco sto canale
prova di scrivermi ma che figata sta
roba che hanno aggiunto ma nuova ogni
tanto se ne escono con certi video che
sono bellissimi complimenti spaccato
next vediamo se scrivo fa vj su youtube
che vi do mi trova visto che bellinello
fa vigili smentito non mi sa che ti sei
perso il secondo video del libro
ok andiamo avanti ovviamente ci sono
tutti i video riguardanti youtube sta
morendo
vabbè youtube divenne una famiglia e
ragione ok andiamo avanti lasciamo
perdere questo argomento la vera storia
di lorenzo insomma con lorenzo ostuni in
arte fa vj lorenzo nato nel 1960 13 7
ero un bimbo come tutti gli altri ea ma
quello non sono io però andiamo avanti
babe grazie per le guance rosse mi mi
sento il mio armadio sopra grazie anche
per l'adr mario questo piatto fa schifo
come lo chiami mangiare questo non lo
ucciderei neanche ad un iter sta roba
qui potete prendere meno che mette
ordinato andare gentilmente sedervi asi
grazie ciao grazie aspetto che prende un
po di panna court
46 dopo cristo lorenzo stato bellissimo
addio aspetto che prende un po di panno
carta dopo cristo penso che l'abbia
pietro colui che da lì a poco sarebbe
diventato il suo fedele levitra un dente
b e nero che o la persona speciale non
solo perché oggettivamente bello ma
perché se lo laici da un dirupo torno
indietro
da qui il famosissimo detto fare magari
se è una grana c'è una roba che mi ha
inquietato tantissimo gesù ma terribile
guardare i cantieri arevalo mi piace
fare guardare i video di cattivi su you
tube man o negativi rossi perché fa vj
aveva paura dei gattini rossi e lo non è
vero così arancione ma rosso i gattini
rossi sono la cosa più terrificante dopo
i ragni e pietro lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo siamo ormai sintonia zio
wow perché tu hai anche 3 dic disse
lorenzo sai perplesso essi anche più di
tennis e pietro euforicamente sicuro di
sé ok se n'è andato e questa è la storia
di como shore diventato youtube
ma no no io ti avevo chiesto la favola
di cappuccetto rosso
tra l'altro la la ti prego la maglia la
maglia cos'è gesù credo che ci sia
dell'arte incompresa in questi video
sono molto colpito dal fatto di non
averli visti per i visti prima in
perdonami zio mi me ne pento
giuro però wow
complimenti spostiamoci invece su dei
video un po più di qualità a livello
visivo e andiamo su come fare i tagli
nei video per diventare fa vj 2.0 e
allora però fare bloccare moby gen
peppo nomi io mi chiamo lorenzo è un po
allora per me fare bloccare moby zen
ho capito cosa sta succedendo lui siede
che pippo che un suo amico gli ha
chiesto come si fa i video come vedi fa
vj a lui ascritti al proprio risposto
caricando il video su youtube
allora però fare bloccare mobili
ciao finta di essere peppo e ascoltiamo
i consigli per diventare fan
e poi se me lo stesso fatto che poi
invece per bloccare in radio non ho
capito niente niente mi sembra stesso
fatto che si è bloccato e poi se me lo
stesso fatto che poi invece fa bloccare
vita o ok cerca di capire come diventare
fa vigente non spiegano tutto qua
l'attuale mike social kids boscato non
si può fare perché ha sbagliato non
funziona così c'è per niente gli addetti
per registrare vai su youtube e clicca
registi registra però non puoi
registrare se stai già registrando con
un programma esterno che questo quindi
si blocca il telefono e se ne accorge
solo nel mentre che sta facendo questo
video quando lo fai
vedi inizia il fidia cricchi qui capito
registrazione non riuscita grazie
questo serve per diventare fa vj vabbè
io direi che possiamo concludere qui
credo di avere un degno erede
io penso di aver fatto il mio tempo ed è
giusto che le varie generazioni facciano
il loro corso e che la gente si abitui a
chi sa ad operare la piattaforma youtube
ica meglio del sottoscritto io vi
ringrazio per avermi seguito
spero che beppe sia un ottimo sostituto
quasi ragazzi se vi è piaciuto lasciato
un momento è un mi piace anche vari
social che come nella descrizione se una
seta questi iscrivetevi ricordatevi
supportate pecco che la strada è ancora
lunga per lui beh ragazzi
[Musica]